Quiero hablarles
o compartirles un hito de un nuevo enfoque
para administrar artículos de un inventario dentro de un depósito.
Hablamos de un escenario de recolectar, empacar, enviar.
Como pista,
esta solución involucra cientos de robots móviles
a veces miles de robots móviles,
que se mueven por todo un depósito. Les hablaré de la solución.
Pero por un instante, solo piensen
en la última vez que pidieron algo en línea.
Estaban sentados en su sofá
y decidieron que sin duda tenían que comprarse esa camiseta roja.
Con un clic lo ponen en su canasta de compras.
Luego deciden que ese par de pantalones verdes
también se ve bien y clic.
Y quizá un par de zapatos azules, clic.
En este punto, ya armaron su pedido.
En ningún instante se detuvieron a pensar
que quizá no es el mejor atuendo.
Pero oprimieron 'Enviar pedido'.
Dos días después, se presenta el paquete a su puerta.
Abren la caja y ¡ups!, ahí tengo mi revoltijo.
¿Se detuvieron a pensar cómo estos artículos del inventario
en realidad encontraron su camino hacia la caja en el depósito?
Estoy aquí para contarles qué es ese tipo que está ahí.
A lo lejos en el centro de la foto,
ven a un típico "trabajador de empaque"
en un escenario de distribución o de cumplimiento de pedidos.
Lo típico es que estos trabajadores dedican de 60 % al 70 % de su día
caminando por toda la bodega.
A menudo caminan de 7 km a más de 15 km
buscando esos artículos del inventario.
No solo es esta una forma improductiva de cumplir pedidos,
también resulta ser una forma insatisfactoria de cumplir pedidos.
Les contaré de cuando me topé con este problema por primera vez.
Estaba por San Francisco en 1999-2000, la era de la burbuja del punto com.
Trabajaba para una espectacular compañía llamada Webvan.
(Risas)
Esta compañía recaudó cientos de millones de dólares con la idea
de hacer entregas de abarrotes por compras en línea.
Llegamos a la conclusión de que no podíamos tener costos eficientes.
Resultó que el comercio electrónico era difícil y muy costoso.
En ese momento particular intentamos reunir 30 artículos de inventario
en unos cuantos acarreos, en una camioneta para entregar a domicilio.
Si lo piensan, nos costaba USD 30.
Imaginen, teníamos una lata de sopa de 89 centavos
que nos costaba un dólar recolectarlo y empacarlo para su trasiego.
Y eso era antes de intentar la entrega a domicilio.
Para acortar la historia, en mi primer año en Webvan,
me di cuenta al hablar con todos los distintos proveedores
que no había una solución específica diseñada para cada base de recolección.
Artículo rojo, verde, azul, poner esas 3 cosas en una caja.
Nos dijimos, tiene que haber una mejor forma de hacer esto.
El manejo de materiales existente está armado para mover
tarimas y cajas a las tiendas.
Claro que Webvan quebró y como un año y medio después,
todavía estaba pensando en este problema, me seguía molestando.
Y empecé a pensarlo otra vez.
Me dije: "Me voy a centrar en lo que quiero como trabajador de empaque".
Cuál es mi visión de cómo debe funcionar...
(Risas)
Me dije: "Enfócate en el problema".
Tengo un pedido aquí y lo que quiero es poner
rojo, verde y azul en esta caja.
Lo que necesito es un sistema donde ponga mi mano y ¡puf!
los productos aparecen y completo el pedido
y ahora estamos pensando,
"sería un enfoque muy centrado en el operador para solucionar el problema.
Eso es lo que necesito, ¿qué tecnología existe para solucionar este problema?"
Pero como ven, los pedidos van y vienen, los productos van y vienen.
Nos permite enfocar al trabajador de empaque como el centro del problema
y dotarlo con herramientas para hacerlos tan productivos como sea posible.
¿Cómo llegué a esta noción?
En realidad vino de un ejercicio de lluvia de ideas,
una técnica que probablemente muchos de Uds. usan,
es esta noción de probar sus ideas.
Toman una hoja en blanco,
luego prueban sus ideas al límite. Al infinito, cero...
En este caso particular, nos retamos con la idea:
¿qué tal si tuviéramos que construir un centro de distribución en China,
donde el costo de mercado es muy bajo?
Digamos, que la mano de obra es barata, el suelo es barato.
Y decimos específicamente:
"¿Qué tal si fuera cero dólares la hora de trabajo directo
y pudiéramos construir un centro de distribución de 93 000 m²?"
Eso naturalmente conduce a ideas como:
"Pongamos a mucha gente en el depósito".
A lo que dije: "Esperen, cero dólares por hora,
lo que haría es 'contratar'
a 10 000 trabajadores que acudan al depósito cada mañana a las 8 horas,
caminen por el depósito y recojan un artículo del inventario
y luego que solo se paren ahí.
Entonces tú tienes la barra de Cap'n Crunch,
tú el Mountain Dew y tú la Diet Coke.
Si la necesito, les llamo, si no solo esperan ahí.
Pero cuando necesito una Diet Coke y les llamo, hablan entre Uds.
Diet Coke aparece, lo recolecto, lo trasiego y está en camino".
¡Caramba!, ¿qué tal si los productos pudieran caminar y hablar por su cuenta?
Esa es una forma poderosa e interesante
de potenciar la organización del depósito.
Claro está, que la mano de obra no es gratis,
lo práctico versus el espectro fabuloso.
(Risas)
Así dijimos estantería móvil, los pondremos en estanterías móviles.
Usaremos robots móviles y moveremos el inventario.
Nos pusimos manos a la obra en eso cuando sentado en mi sofá en 2008...
¿Vieron la ceremonia de apertura de los JJ.OO. de Beijing?
Por poco me caigo del sofá cuando vi eso.
¡Eso es!
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Pondremos a miles de personas en el piso del depósito, el piso del estadio.
Resulta curioso, esto está relacionado con la idea
de crear arte digital impresionante increíblemente poderoso,
todo sin computadora, me dijeron,
era todo coordinación y comunicación punto a punto.
Tú te paras, yo me agacho.
E hicieron arte fabuloso.
Habla del poder del surgimiento
en sistemas cuando dejan que las cosas empiecen a hablar entre sí.
Eso fue una partecita de la travesía.
Por supuesto, ¿de esta idea qué se convirtió en realidad práctica?
Aquí está un depósito, un centro
de recolección, empaque y envío con unos 10 mil números de referencia.
Les llamamos plumas rojas, plumas verdes y post-it amarillos.
Mandamos pequeños robots naranjas para recoger anaqueles azules
y los entregamos a un lado del edificio.
Así todos los trabajadores de recolección permanecen en la periferia.
La maniobra aquí es recolectar los anaqueles,
ponerlos en la banda y entregarlos directamente al trabajador de empaque.
La vida de los trabajadores es completamente diferente.
En vez de vagar por el depósito, permanecen quietos
en una estación de recolección como ésta
y cada producto en el edificio puede ahora llegarles.
Así el proceso es muy productivo,
a su alcance, recolecta un artículo, escanea el código de barra, lo empaca.
Cuando se dan la vuelta,
hay otro producto listo para ser recolectado y empacado.
Eliminamos todo el tiempo de espera, perdido,
de búsqueda, de caminar sin valor agregado
y desarrollamos un forma de alta confiabilidad de recolección de pedidos,
donde apuntan con un láser, escanean el código electrónico
y luego indican con una luz a cuál caja debe ir.
Es más productivo, más preciso y resulta
que es un ambiente de trabajo más interesante para estos trabajadores.
De hecho cumplen con todo el pedido.
Así que hacen rojo, verde y azul y no solo una parte.
Se sienten un poco más en control de su ambiente.
Así los efectos secundarios de este enfoque
es lo que en verdad nos sorprendió.
Sabíamos que iba a ser más productivo.
Pero no nos dimos cuenta cómo se fue permeando
esta forma de pensar en otras funciones del depósito.
La efectividad de este enfoque dentro del centro de distribución
es que lo transforma en una máquina de procesamiento paralelo masivo.
Otra vez, esto es una fertilización cruzada de ideas.
Aquí hay un depósito y estamos pensando
en arquitecturas de supercomputadora de procesamiento en paralelo.
La noción aquí es que tienen
10 trabajadores a la derecha de la pantalla
ahora todos son trabajadores de empaque autónomos independientes.
Si el trabajador de la estación 3 necesita ir al baño,
no hay impacto en la productividad de los otros 9 trabajadores.
Contrasten eso, con el método tradicional del uso de la banda transportadora.
Cuando alguien les pasa el pedido,
le ponen algo y lo pasan a la banda corriendo.
Todos tienen que estar en su lugar para que el proceso en serie funcione.
Esto se convierte en una forma más robusta de concebir el depósito.
Debajo del toldo se pone interesante porque estamos rastreando
la popularidad de los productos.
Y estamos usando algoritmos adaptativos y dinámicos
para ajustar el piso del depósito.
Lo que ven aquí es la semana previa al día de San Valentín.
Todo el dulce polvoso rosa se ha movido al frente del edificio
y se recolecta para llenar pedidos en las estaciones de recolección.
Vengan 2 días después de San Valentín y el dulce que quedó,
todo se ha recorrido a la parte posterior del depósito
y ocupa la zona más templada en el mapa térmico aquí.
Otro efecto secundario de este enfoque que usa el procesamiento en paralelo
es que estas cosas se pueden escalar a lo 'hipergigante'.
(Risas)
Sea que tengan 2 estaciones de recolección, 20 estaciones
o 200 estaciones, los algoritmos de planeación de ruta
y todos los algoritmos de inventario funcionan.
En este ejemplo ven que el inventario
ocupa ahora todo el perímetro del edificio,
porque es ahí donde están las estaciones de recolección.
Los clasifican ellos mismos.
Concluyo con un video final
que muestra cómo se desarrolla esto
en un día de la vida del trabajador de empaque
Como dijimos, el proceso es mover el inventario por la carretera
y luego encuentra su camino hacia las estaciones de recolección.
Nuestro software tras bambalinas
entiende lo que pasa en cada estación,
dirigimos el depósito por toda la carretera
e intentamos ponerlo en una sistema de cola
que presente el trabajo al trabajador de empaque.
Lo interesante es que podemos adaptar
la velocidadde recolección de los trabajadores.
Los más rápidos obtienen más anaqueles y los más lentos, menos.
Pero el trabajador ahora experimenta cabalmente
lo que describimos antes.
Saca su mano, el producto le brinca
o tiene que alzarlo y tomarlo.
Lo escanea y lo pone en la canasta.
Y todo el resto de la tecnología está tras bambalinas.
Así el trabajador se concentra en la parte de recolección y empaque.
Nunca tiene tiempos muertos ni tiene que dejar su puesto.
De hecho pensamos que no solo es más productivo
y más preciso para cumplir los pedidos
sino que creemos que es una forma más satisfactoria de cumplir pedidos.
Podemos decir esto porque los trabajadores
en muchos de estos edificios ahora compiten
por el privilegio de trabajar en la zona KIVA.
Y a veces los sorprendemos en videos testimoniales
diciendo cosas como
que tienen más energía al final del día para jugar son sus nietos
o en una ocasión alguien dijo, "En la zona KIVA no hay estrés
y de hecho he dejado de tomar la medicina para la presión".
(Risas)
Eso fue con un distribuidor farmacéutico, que nos pidió que no usáramos ese video.
Hoy quiero dejarles la noción de que
cuando dejan que las cosas empiecen a pensar y caminar
y que hablen por su cuenta, surgen procesos interesantes y productivos.
Creo que el siguiente paso es
que vayan a la puerta, recojan esa caja de lo que pidieron en línea,
la abran y el revoltijo esté ahí;
sentirán cierto asombro de si un robot
asistió en la recolección y empaque de ese pedido.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)